Figaro live 15 heures 22 nous sommes en
direct merci d'être avec nous avec cette
question cet après-midi Jean-Luc
Mélenchon va-t-il avaler la gauche tout
cru il rêve d'être Premier ministre mais
pour cela il faut négocier négocier et
sa négocie vraiment mais qu'est-ce que
ça négocie et bien vous avez la réponse
ce matin dans le dans le Figaro et ceux
qui vous donnent la réponse ce matin ils
sont avec moi Sophie Ravinel pierre
Lepeletier bonjour
journaliste politique au Figaro en
charge de la gauche évidemment merci
m'accompagner aujourd'hui donc vous
signez ce dossier ce matin je montre
quand même dans les premières pages du
Figaro alors moi j'ai j'ai tout surligné
en gros c'est vous dire qu'il y a plein
de choses qui m'intéressent et on va en
parler ensemble mais avant de parler de
ces négociations je voudrais que vous
m'expliquiez
combien de députés la gauche et la
France insoumise peut avoir en partant
dispersés comme à la présidentielle et
qu'est-ce que ça changerait si il
partait ensemble avec une coalition LFI
PS Europe écologie des Verts et les
communistes qu'est-ce que ça change en
terme de nombre on a une idée l'objectif
c'est 28 289 c'est la moitié de 579 de
577 c'est la majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée et donc c'est ça qu'ils
veulent évidemment pour mettre installé
Jean-Luc Mélenchon puisque c'est un
accord de législature mais un accord de
gouvernement qui est en train d'essayer
d'être
discuté c'est un peu compliqué
après en réalité je sais pas combien
est-ce qu'ils peuvent espérer en tout
cas la fourchette basse c'est de garder
ce qu'ils ont déjà tous en termes de
députés mais bien sûr
soixantaine entre le PS les communistes
et les filles les écolos n'ont pas de
n'ont pas de députés donc 60 mais en
gros 60 c'est s'ils partent disperser
j'imagine qu'ensemble on vise plus de
189 c'est possible ou pas ça semble
quand même compliqué même si voilà c'est
l'ambition il préfère le afficher grand
pour mobiliser le plus possible les
électeurs si double déjà ce qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui ils seront contents puisque
ils apparaîtront un peu comme une des
seules oppositions Emmanuel Macron voir
l'opposition principale à Emmanuel
Macron à l'Assemblée alors une grande
question pour pour bien comprendre les
enjeux de ces négociations pour
s'assurer un financement les
législatives c'est très important est-ce
que vous pouvez m'expliquer ça veut dire
que les parties notamment le Parti
socialiste ne peut pas accepter de ne
présenter que 20 candidats ça c'est
impossible pour absolument et je crois
qu'il faut pour la règle je parle sous
ton contrôle pierre mais c'est 1% à
minima dans 50 circonscriptions un euro
70 par voie des lecteurs 1% des scores
dans 50 circonscriptions ça c'est
important donc déjà pour se faire
financer il faut mettre 50 candidats
quelquefois il est plus intéressant pour
certains partis notamment les Europe
Écologie l'hiver qui sont un peu les
spécialistes de genre de calcul plus
intéressant d'avoir une multitude de
candidats dans toutes les
circonscriptions plutôt que quelques-uns
qui font des gros scores ça c'est une
chose et c'est un financement on peut
regretter que la vie politique française
soit financée de cette façon là chez nos
voisins allemands par exemple quand vous
recevez votre fiche d'impôt vous pouvez
cocher en disant voilà le parti que je
souhaite
les insoumis les communistes et c'est le
financement public par volonté de des
électeurs chez nous c'est différent et
ça ne se base que sur cette élection là
et donc une fois tous les 5 ans et donc
c'est on comprend la pression qu'il y a
mais évidemment la pression n'est pas
que financière parce que contrairement à
Marine Le Pen qui a clairement affiché
l'idée que non jamais elle ne pourrait
être chef de gouvernement Jean-Luc
Mélenchon entretient ça pour susciter
une dynamique évidemment autour de lui
bon on a les enjeux passons à ces
négociations vous pouvez réagir
évidemment sur Le Figaro.fr sur Facebook
sur Youtube des pros ils savent tout ils
sont dans les arcanes de ces
négociations aux parties socialistes à
la France insoumise et aux autres
parties de gauche qu'est-ce qu'ils
attendent pierre les insoumis très
clairement qu'est-ce qu'il propose pour
l'instant et est-ce que c'est tenable
pour les autres ils aimeraient
rassembler le plus largement possible
effectivement qu'on le disait Sophie
pour espérer avoir une majorité et avoir
un jury que Mélenchon à Matignon en
premier ministre après voilà il demande
quand même de base programmatique sur
laquelle le programme d'abord parce que
ça c'est important est-ce que sur le
programme les autres peuvent s'accorder
et ben étonnamment et nous qui les
suivants depuis plusieurs années moi on
se rend compte que certains bougent plus
rapidement très rapidement contrairement
à l'heure qu'ils étaient quand même
assez figés je pense par exemple à la
question des désobéissances des traités
européens c'est fondamental ce sujet là
pour les insoumis et on se rend compte
que finalement les socialistes les
écologistes qui sont leur ADN
pro-européen commence à bouger en disant
les écolos hier disait que ce n'était
plus une ligne rouge infranchissable
donc voilà ça bouge un petit peu et
c'est principalement cette question
européenne il y en a d'autres mais qui
qui joue dans les négociations qu'il
faut savoir c'est que en fait chez eux
ça a été très bien résumé ce matin par
Fabien Roussel donc le patron des
communistes qui a organisé une petite
conférence de presse très suivie
d'ailleurs en milieu de journée
aujourd'hui ils disent qu'il faut c'est
qu'il y ait 10 points de programmes sur
lesquels on puisse à peu près tous
on a vu juste avant les images des
négociations hier avec tous ces tous ces
historiques
alors on va en parler Emmanuel Bompard
est sorti en disant il y a 800 points
dans le programme de la France insoumise
bon nous on est prêt à transiger sur
certains vous me dites il faut quand
même se mettre d'accord sur 10 points
précis ce sont les communistes qui dit
ça globalement je pense qu'il y a
effectivement un accord de législature
qui pourrait être un accord de
gouvernement c'est 10 points principaux
les communistes ils ont l'habitude ils
ont déjà fait deux campagnes
présidentielles avec les insoumis avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon en l'occurrence
pour les socialistes c'est plus
compliqué et François Hollande qui était
ce matin m'inviter France Info il a très
bien résumé en disant mais enfin est-ce
que le Parti socialiste a tellement
changé sur l'OTAN est-ce que le Parti
socialiste a tellement changé sur la
retraite est-ce que le Parti socialiste
a tellement changé sur tous ces points
qui normalement devrait faire qu'il y
ait une ligne rouge entre les
socialistes et les insoumis pendant la
campagne présidentielle donc il y a deux
mois de ça on va en parler des
socialistes juste je précise vous voyez
ce titre Mélenchon peut-il devenir
Premier ministre pas nommé par Emmanuel
Macron évidemment c'est en cas de
victoire aux élections législatives
juste avant qu'on parle des socialistes
je vous ai demandé ce qu'attendait les
insoumis en terme de programme qu'est-ce
qu'il propose et qu'est-ce qu'ils
attendent en termes de siège vont être
dit 577 circonscriptions ils en veulent
289 ans en résultat mais je veux dire
ils vont proposer aux parties socialiste
de s'aligner sur combien de
circonscriptions ça c'est des
négociations on sait parce que
il y a des tableaux XL alors Julien
Bayou le patron des écologistes
parce qu'il a assisté à la conférence de
presse des écologistes mais enfin c'est
totalement vin d'essayer de vous résumer
ça avec tout le bien toute la volonté
que nous aurions de pouvoir expliquer ça
à nos auditeurs téléspectateurs mais de
fait ça bouge tous les jours ce que les
communistes m'ont dit par exemple à midi
c'est que bon bah vous vous apprenez à
Vénissieux nous c'est une ville qui est
quand même communiste depuis des
décennies vous nous envoyez un jeune
parisien à aboie pour venir
dans une ville communiste on peut
peut-être en discuter pareil pour
Philippe Rio en Île-de-France pareil
pour Nicolas sangsue je crois en un lois
pareil pour si je ne me trompe pas
Nicolas censure et il y en a d'autres
comme ça donc chacun en fait voudrait un
prêt carré réservé ça se joue c'est
vraiment un peu
ces conditions les insoumis ont commencé
les discussions en disant qu'il voulait
une répartition proportionnelle aux
résultats de la présidentielle
évidemment ça n'arrangeait absolument
pas les écologistes et les communistes
et les socialistes les écologistes on
dit nous on accepte effectivement on
prend acte des résultats du premier tour
mais on veut qui on prenne en compte les
élections intermédiaires les européennes
municipales où ils sont arrivés plus
haut les communistes ils sont
complètement
nulsent il faut qu'on y ait il faut
qu'on prenne en compte l'ancrage
territorial parce qu'on a plusieurs
conseillers départementaux de
conseillers et donc il faut que tout ça
prend en compte donc c'est quand même
très compliqué
pendant la campagne des législatives
donc en fait c'est assez incertain alors
les socialistes je vous lis j'ai vu qui
négocie dans dans ces négociations qui
ont commencé hier et là on voit quand
même que le Parti socialiste a perdu de
sa splendeur pardon pierre Jouvet
Sébastien vincini Boris Vallaud Laurent
Baumel et Christophe Clergeot je pense
que les gens ne savent pas qui sont ces
personnes étaient politiques Boris valop
peut-être c'est vrai alors qu'en face
c'est pas forcément des stars mais
manuel Bompard Adrien catenas Manon
brille Alexis Corbière et Coquerel ce
sont des personnalités qui ont émergé
qu'on connaît peut-être un peu plus la
splendeur du PS a disparu il y a pas de
mieux pardon excusez-moi de ces
personnes là pour négocier
de cette nouvelle génération de
quarantenaires aimeraient un peu prendre
maintenant le devant de la scène
d'accord et forcément ça passe par des
périodes où on les connaît pas ou c'est
des nouvelles têtes on se demande qui
sont ces gens et avec le pari que dans
quelques mois dans quelques années et ce
seront eux qui seront en commande si je
vous parle de Carole delguin si je oui
de Michael Delafosse Matthieu Klein
Johanna Roland voilà mais ce ne sont pas
eux qui sont les grands-mères et qui
sont aujourd'hui la force du Parti
socialiste la force du Parti socialiste
aujourd'hui elle est locale et non plus
nationale et donc c'est ça qui va aussi
être tout l'enjeu de ces législatives
c'est de savoir si elles sont
l'émanation d'une campagne nationale
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon en tête
d'affiches et un vote pour une troisième
tour insoumis et donc la création d'un
gouvernement avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou
est-ce que c'est l'émanation de ces
forces locales qui restent socialistes
beaucoup aussi écologiste mais
socialiste un petit peu parce que j'ai
l'impression que les pontes qu'il reste
des éléphants du Parti socialiste
Stéphane Le Foll François Hollande
notamment eux sont contre cette alliance
avec la France insoumise il y a une
réunion mardi soir vous nous avez
raconté aussi dans le Figaro il y a deux
jours je crois
racontez-moi ça ça s'est pas bien passé
veut pas dire que chez les socialistes
il se réunissent généralement à 19h 20h
et à minuit 1h du matin tout le monde
sort bouillonne et jusqu'à 2-3 heures du
matin tout le monde s'envoie des SMS des
messages les règlements de compte en
direct avec les journalistes en arbitre
et c'est souvent très amusant très
intéressant c'est le fruit d'un parti en
total recomposition c'est vrai
qu'Olivier fort là il est en train de de
il a fait plusieurs mouvements
successifs qui sont pas forcément
compréhensibles mais c'est vrai qu'il a
été élu en 2018 sur cette ligne
d'ouverture cette ligne d'alliance avec
les écologistes même en 2019 il disait
mais si jamais Jean-Luc Mélenchon
voulait être celui qui nous représente
tous il faudrait en discuter il ne
l'écartait pas sauf que en fait il a été
ensuite rapatriés vers une ligne
beaucoup plus centrale sans triste sur
la force du Parti socialiste avec un
Hidalgo qui paradoxalement elle aussi a
été élu à Paris sur une ligne
d'ouverture et puis au moment de la
présidentielle c'est un peu rétréci sur
une ligne purement socialiste
et donc c'est une preuve pour Olivier
Faure qui false se ressentir il faut pas
perdre en tête l'idée que dans les
différents congrès dernier vote interne
qu'ils ont eu la ligne défendue par
Olivier Faure et toute cette nouvelle
génération était quand même arrivé
majoritaire contrairement à celle de
Stéphane Le folle et d'autres dit
éléphants ou hollandais socialiste qui
sont à chaque fois arrivés en minorité
et donc finalement il y a quelque chose
d'assez frustrant chez la nouvelle les
jeunes les plus jeunes disons qui disent
on n'est pas assez entendu alors que les
anciens ne par leur aura d'anciens
ministres qui gardent toujours
des anciens qui sont avec les nouveaux
et des nouveaux qui sont avec les
anciens c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
enfants
c'est une question de génération alors
étonnamment même si vous pouvez imaginer
que la France insoumise et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon était en conflit on le sait
depuis plusieurs années avec les le
Parti socialiste c'est avec eux que ça
avance le mieux quelles sont les
arguments du Parti socialiste eux
qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent apporter aux
insoumis ça c'est toute la ils ont pas
envie de se faire manger un peu la
surprise du chef d'hier ou finalement on
pensait qu'il allait être d'accord sur
rien et en fait sont sortis en étant
quasiment d'accord sur tout même sur des
points que les socialistes ont porté
comme la loi el khomri par exemple il y
a aussi la retraite à 60 ans ou
finalement un Hidalgo ne voulait pas
retenir dessus voilà sur l'Union
européenne moi je me rappelle d'avoir
suivi un Hidalgo pour son dernier
meeting au Cirque d'Hiver elle cognait
vraiment dur contre Jean-Luc Mélenchon
sur la guerre en Ukraine voilà elle est
là aujourd'hui on sent que bon on peut
se mettre d'accord donc c'est vraiment
une surprise et les insoumis au disent
qu'ils sont les premiers surpris je vous
lis ce matin justement honnêtement on
n'avait pas l'impression de discuter
avec le même PS qu'il y a deux ou trois
ans c'est ce que dit manuel bon et puis
pierre Jouvet le socialiste lui dit il y
a pas de blocage insurmontable alors
après à quel point est-ce cynique
un coup de poker menteur tout le monde a
intérêt tout le monde puisse avoir un
accord entre les socialistes et les
insoumis il faut quand même se souvenir
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est un ancien
socialiste il y a une cote naturalité
entre une poursuite d'une ligne on peut
dire qu'il redresse tous les deux le
drapeau de la gauche c'est moins évident
avec les écologistes sachant que les
écologistes ils sont un peu divisés
entre eux donc déjà cette difficulté là
les socialistes avec ces deux phrases de
ce matin François Hollande qui dit je
cite c'est sur France Info cette
coalition serait mortifère inacceptable
et signifierait la disparition du PS et
Stéphane Le Foll l'ancien ministre de
l'Agriculture de François Hollande dit
le PS ne se présenterait que dans 15 à
20 circonscriptions avec cette coalition
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai c'est
intenable
de toutes parts je pense que personne ne
sait exactement combien il va de
circonscriptions c'est c'est une très
grosse pression évidemment et encore une
fois je pense que
moi ce que je hier donc j'ai fait un
entretien avec avec Olivier fort et je
lui disais mais pas premier secrétaire
du Parti socialiste c'est je lui disais
mais alors comment est-ce que vous allez
vous entendre il y a des
circonscriptions dans lesquelles c'est
quand même très tendu avec les insoumis
il me dit mais de toute façon l'accord
ne concernera que ceux qui sont d'accord
et que ceux qui ont signé et donc une
coalition forcément nationale de
l'ensemble des socialistes il est
socialistes par exemple ceux qui l'a
invité lors du BN interdit donc vous
parliez en disant mais le bureau
national du Parti socialiste les
acronymes on devrait avoir 50 centimes
pour chaque acronyme et donc à l'issue
de ce bureau national une grosse colère
et ras-le-bol si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord partez et donc c'est là-dessus
qu'on a glosé et que ça a un petit peu
fonctionné toute la nuit et de fait si
ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec son
avec l'accord de mandature de
législature et bien ils ne sont pas ce
n'est pas le cas par exemple à Paris
dans la 15e
circonscription de Paris qui est celle
du 20e arrondissement à l'est il y a une
députée qu'on peut considérer sortante
parce que son élection a été invalidée
il y a quelques mois l'AMIA et la rage
mais la mienne n'est pas d'accord avec
l'accord de législatures que compte
signer Olivier Faure
conception un candidat LFI absolument et
soutenu par le Parti socialiste allez on
va faire on va avancer on va aller sur
les écologistes mais je vais le faire à
chaque fois pourcentage de chance
aujourd'hui si vous aviez déterminé un
pourcentage de chance d'accord entre le
PS et LFI allez un chiffre comme ça 70
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal quand même
bon on va voir parce que les écolos
c'est plutôt vous pierre et on y vient
qu'est-ce qui se passe les écologistes
là en ce moment là c'est la grande
Histoire des écologistes c'est on a
l'impression que ça avance et au final
il faut rediscuter rediscuter et encore
rediscuter tous ensemble et il y a
tellement des différences entre eux d'un
point de vue stratégique que finalement
ça n'avance pas du tout donc c'est entre
qui et qui qui sont les les pôles des
écologistes
encore une fois on peut reprendre
l'exemple des la désobéissance des
traités européens ou finalement tout le
monde n'est pas sur la même ligne du
tout chez les Verts des plus
fédéralistes donc à plus les proches de
Yannick Jadot qui ne veulent pas
entendre parler de désobéir aux traités
il considèrent au contraire que c'est
l'Union européenne qui doit qui doit
permettre de faire les choses et à
l'aile gauche du parti qui finalement
assez proche de la fille donc pour
mettre tout ça dans le même c'est quand
même un petit peu compliqué et
d'ailleurs les insoumis qu'on rencontre
alors ils sont un peu perdus ils sont
des bonnes presque en disant régler vos
problèmes et les insoumis vous revenez
vers nous les insoumis eux qui au moins
c'est vrai qu'il y a une ligne définie
par quelques-uns en fait alors tout
l'inverse des verres et donc quand les
discutent les deux troupes discutent
ensemble ils ne se comprennent pas ils
ont parfois même l'impression de ne pas
parler le même langage tellement
leur culture politique et vraiment
différent si je peux me permettre c'est
vraiment la formation qui diffère chez
les insoumis et ELV e l V c'est vraiment
l'expression du parti le plus
démocratique d'abord c'est un parti
politique ce que ne sont pas les
insoumis ensuite c'est un parti où la
discussion est à la base de toute la
culture des couleurs de leur porte quoi
d'accord
et pas de réflexion ce qui est l'inverse
des écologistes qui sont dans la
réflexion énormément dans l'action aussi
et donc ça ça provoque et c'est très
amusant de voir les étincelles et les
incompréhensions entre eux c'est assez
énorme et finalement les socialistes
sont assez proches des insoumis
là-dessus ils ont une culture qui est
quand même plus proche entre eux que les
écologistes je vous lis quand même avec
cette socialistes quand même après c'est
vrai qu'il y a un rapport à l'autorité
qui reste un petit peu plus ordonnée que
chez les écologistes mais enfin le Parti
socialiste c'est une très grosse
sculpture de débat alors que chez
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il n'y a pas une tête
qui ressort plus forte que les autres
c'est de voir que la formation de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon la formation
d'Emmanuel Macron la formation de Marine
Le Pen et d'ailleurs qui forme trois
aimants en deçà desquels les autres
parties n'existent plus et bien c'est
parti là il n'existe que par la
personnalisation de leur chef et pour
moi c'est vraiment ça avec ces tâchis
cette affiche pour les législatives où
on ne voit que Jean-Luc Mélenchon on va
y venir à cette question de l'affiche de
l'affichage de l'habillage autour de
cette campagne je vous dis quand même
avec ce représentant LFI un cadre LFI je
ne sais pas qui est le chef j'ai peur
que leur bordel interne fasse échouer
les choses ça pourrait bloquer vraiment
une scission chez les Verts très
clairement est-ce que certains peuvent
partir chez Jean-Luc Mélenchon et une
autre partie restée avec Yannick Jadot
c'est tout le cas dans Le Parisien
en disant je crains que le parti
n'expose alors je pense qu'on l'a dit à
de nombreuses périodes certains
peut-être de nos auditeurs se
souviendront de la firme de la grande
époque Cécile Duflot de de
et c'est vrai que déjà il y avait eu et
des tensions très fortes entre eux mais
là si jamais il devait se créer une
formation entre les insoumis et Emmanuel
Macron les sociaux-démocrates sont
tentés de faire venir certains est-ce
que Delphine bateau par exemple qui a
été une des portes-parents de Yannick
Jadot à cette appétence pour les
insoumis je ne crois pas elle a vraiment
manifesté elle le fait pendant toute la
campagne qu'il y avait des différences
radicales elle est très radicale mais
pas du tout sur les questions qui sont
chez les insoumis plus ou moins de libre
choix notamment dans le rapport à la
République 15h43 nous sommes en direct
on se demande et vous le voyez sur le
petit synthé en bas Jean-Luc Mélenchon
peut-il vraiment devenir Premier
ministre après les législatives
évidemment en cas de victoire de la
gauche et on essaye de savoir s'il peut
y avoir une alliance à gauche quelle est
l'espérance quel est le pouvoir de
nuisances si j'ose dire des vers auprès
des insoumis parce que les socialistes
ont un ancrage local ils ont déjà des
députés c'est pas le cas je des verres
qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent proposer à LFI
eux
ils ont un ancrage local ils pensent
pouvoir effectivement leur apporter il y
a un agrandissement tout simplement de
ce qui ce que j'ai envie de mélench
champagne l'Union Populaire et donc plus
d'importance après c'est vrai que quand
on voit le score de Yannick Jadot ça
reste limité et d'ailleurs un insoumis
me disait il y a quelques jours s'il n'y
a pas d'accord tant pis de toute façon
c'est eux qui ont besoin de nous plus
que nous nous avons besoin mais ils ont
Bordeaux ils ont Lyon ils entourent ils
ont Marseille relativement payant qui
est plutôt socialiste et qui était
plutôt soutien de Taubira ils ont
Strasbourg ils ont Poitiers quand même
des villes assez costaudes et puis
l'importante et c'est le même électorat
que celui des insoumis donc il peut y
avoir des batailles sachant que pour ces
législatives il faut douze et demi des
inscrits pour pouvoir être sélectionné
pour pouvoir rentrer au deuxième tour
mais évidemment en fonction du taux de
participation qui se répète ça peut
monter jusqu'à 20 25%. et donc s'il y
avait deux candidats de gauche ça
pourrait très bien être l'effacement un
total de à gauche donc l'enjeu est
colossal allez pourcentage de chance
d'accord entre les Verts et les filles
on a fait avec le Parti socialiste nous
a dit 70%
60 40
50 vous êtes en train de me dire ça bon
en tout cas les 60 60 dans quel sens 60
pour un accord pour un accord allez donc
vous êtes plutôt positif les deux
parties prenantes sont à peu près sur la
même ligne je lis Requiem for a Dream
sur sur Le Figaro.fr qui me dit
Mélenchon a une excellente stratégie
c'est l'homme fort de la gauche il a
raison d'appuyer fort voilà pour ce
commentaire alors on va parler des
affiches est-ce que les vers les
socialistes les communistes peuvent
accepter d'avoir une affiche avec leur
logo d'accord mais derrière leurs
candidats ou même devant c'est ça se
trouve la figure de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
eux disent oui franchement la plupart
disent alors il faudra pas que ça soit
comme la première affiche qu'on a tous
vu ou ces Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors on
peut la montrer regardez elle est là
ça a été très mal perçu d'ailleurs que
cette affiche short pendant les
négociations cette fois perçu par les
socialistes les écologistes d'ailleurs
les écologistes disaient nous aussi on a
préparé une affiche mais on l'a pas
sorti pas pour respect pour nos
partenaires de gauche après si un lac
aussi un accord arrive les écologistes
disent on comprend la stratégie et on
accepte que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
apparaissent enfin il y aura une logique
à ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon apparaissent
sur une photo mais symboliquement c'est
fort alors je veux bien entendre les
accords etc symboliquement voir partout
en France sur tous les panneaux
d'affichage devant les écoles devant les
mairies Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec le logo
du Parti socialiste j'imagine que ça
donne encore qu'elle soit collées ces
affiches parce qu'à mon avis ça va
beaucoup dépendre de la volonté de
chacun des candidats évidemment c'est
une pression de de négociation
évidemment ça peut bouger évidemment ça
peut être un bout de cette affiche et
une autre affiche à côté
ça va énormément j'ai l'impression que
c'est une vraie question le troisième
tour c'est vraiment le pari du troisième
c'est l'Union Populaire les écologistes
proposent union populaire écologiste
propose gauche écologiste
gauche écologiste voilà
mais on va aussi se battre pour ça il y
a une question d'ego si vous me parlez
tout à l'heure c'est de Villeurbanne je
crois que c'est ça ça peut bloquer sur
des sur des noms vous parlez de ta
Boisse notamment est-ce que les
socialistes peuvent te dire ta boivent
si vous ne savez pas qui c'est c'était
un journaliste militant condamné
notamment pour pour provoquer à la haine
raciale il me semble qu'est-ce que les
socialistes peuvent dire et ce qu'ils
peuvent bloquer certains noms et dire on
veut bien être d'accord sur l'ensemble
du territoire sur plein de
circonscription mais cette personne on
ne la veut pas est-ce que c'est possible
ça fait partie du cadre des négociations
il est pas évident que la France
insoumise cède moi mon option c'est que
son nom a été envoyé c'est d'ailleurs
nous au Figaro qu'il avait annoncé en
premier un vendredi soir là encore au
milieu de la nuit ça se passe souvent
dans ces cadres là c'est assez amusant
c'est souvent ça alors que chez elle on
l'a vu c'est plutôt on se rejoint on se
rejoint en début de matinée et on
discute puisque jusqu'en début
d'après-midi
et donc sur toute la boivent et et donc
qui est très sympathique par ailleurs et
de fait comme vous le soulignez il a été
condamné pour pour un jeu racial c'est
un garçon qui a un parcours un peu
compliqué qui a qui s'est présenté une
première fois à l'âge de 19 ans
je crois que c'était à Échirolles en
Isère et qu'il a donc va aller à une
centaine de kilomètres donc prétend
aller à Vénissieux c'est un garçon que
moi je je considère comme très sincère
dans ces engagements et qui
effectivement est extrêmement
controversé très proche du et c'est tout
le rapport que la France insoumise
entretient avec les quartiers les
quartiers populaires dans lesquels
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a fait des scores
assez colossaux assez énorme et donc ce
jeune confrère même si c'est mis en
retrait de son activité de journaliste
parce qu'ils travaillaient pour le média
qui est la télévision assez proche des
insoumis bien sûr et bien ta voix faites
un peu la caution de ces quartiers
populaires lui-même se revendique de sa
foi musulmane se revendique de son
origine dans ses quartiers populaires
s'engagent pour la défense des droits de
la justice sociale et il est une caution
il a été en froid assez souvent
d'ailleurs y compris avec certains
membres de des insoumis je ne sais pas
si son nom a été mis là pour mieux le
retirer dans le cadre des négociations
ou si vraiment c'est une condition
sinequanone on parle aussi dans le
papier que vous aviez la gentillesse de
promouvoir tout à l'heure de Gabriel
Lamarque et le logement
vous pouvez le sur le site aussi mais il
est 15h49 on peut le trouver encore dans
les kiosque absolument il doit en rester
quelques-uns le gendre de Gabriel Amar
le gendre de Jean-Luc Mélenchon Gabriel
Lamarque qui se Villeurbanne c'est ça
alors
c'est la même chose mais parler tout à
l'heure de la 15e circonscription c'est
la même chose là il pour il se pourrait
que le candidat socialiste ne se retire
pas par exemple et décide de rester et
d'avoir à ces endroits là des endroits
précis
c'est évident toutes les
circonscriptions l'accord soit
parfaitement respecté
d'avoir des candidats dissident on parle
des communistes en un mot on va le faire
rapidement là aussi dès le lendemain du
premier tour on a l'impression qu'il y a
eu un rapprochement entre entre Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et Fabien Roussel et là je
vous lis ce matin l'état d'esprit
général n'est pas bon fustige également
un élu comme une liste il y a une
conférence de presse qu'elle Sophie
était ce matin alors est-ce que ça a
changé parce que ça vous l'avez écrit
hier un petit peu l'objectif pour Fabien
Roussel c'est d'aller plus loin et plus
vite plus haut et plus large donc en
fait il voudrait vraiment je pense être
lui un petit peu l'organisateur le
casque bleu entre les quatre formations
il voudrait aussi que tout le monde
descende dans la rue qui est une photo
d'affichage un dimanche de plus
travaillé pour nous la fête du travail
le premier mai le rassembleur il
voudrait occuper ce poste Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ne l'a toujours pas rappelé
sur son téléphone portable il y a eu
quand même un gros froid absolument il y
a eu un gros froid ils sont vraiment ils
sont vraiment froid on sait que pendant
la campagne ça a été dur hein sur
plusieurs questions ou on a vu qu'il y
avait de rédigeants divergence sur le
nucléaire sur la laïcité sur la sécurité
c'est c'est des vrais problèmes qu'on ne
peut pas qu'on ne peut pas combler c'est
pas c'est pas problématique c'est
vraiment sur les circonscriptions
et puis c'est un groupe qui pèse un peu
plus que les écologistes ils ont 11
députés 16 en tout avec avec des dans le
groupe parlementaires avec des élus
divers gauche d'outre-mer c'est
quasiment autant que les insoumis alors
aussi ils ont quelque chose de défendre
bah ils aimeraient surtout garder leur
groupe c'est ça leur groupe sanguin
parce que mine de rien avoir un groupe à
l'Assemblée c'est avoir les moyens
d'avoir une exposition tout dépend des
textes autant de paroles et même
présenter des textes en leur déniche
parlementaires donc ce n'est pas rien et
donc ils tiennent en fait absolument à
défendre ce qu'on appelle leur sortant
les députés qui sont déjà en place et
qui se représentent et quelques autres
et quelques autres bien sûr mon
pourcentage de chance la même question
d'accord entre le PCF et lsfi 90
quasiment alors attendez mais vous me
dites 70% de chance d'accord avec le
Parti socialiste 60 avec les Verts 90
avec les communistes
bon alors à quand la fumée blanche c'est
quoi le programme là il aimerait aboutir
dans l'idéal avant la fin de la semaine
et comme de Sophie avant le le 1er mai
une photo on imagine Pierre et moi sur
le terrain dimanche si possible
effectivement des fils ensemble les
derniers ces dernières heures montrent
que ça peut être plus compliqué que
prévu après faut pas que c'est trop que
ça traîne non plus parce qu'il y a tous
les
pour les affiches les fameuses et la
date de dépôt des candidatures ça c'est
plus loin il y a le temps c'est un peu
plus loin en mai
parce que j'étais sur place mais de fait
je ne l'ai pas interviewée les viewers
lui dire mais enfin est-ce que vous
voulez bien nous dire à quel moment si
vous allez vous présenter en bas il lui
reste encore au moins une vingtaine de
jours pour se décider passer certains
que l'ancien chef de l'État est en vie
de redescendre sur les bancs de
l'Assemblée mais ce n'est pas exclu non
plus
allez dernière question on essaie de
répondre à cette question Mélenchon
peut-il vraiment devenir Premier
ministre est-ce qu'il a une chance
vraiment honnêtement
semble quand même compliqué et d'accéder
pour eux une moitié d'assemblée
nationale des missiles ça voudrait dire
qu'il faut gagner dans la moitié des
circonscriptions c'est une élections à
deux tours donc il suffit qu'il y a un
insoumise mon tour pour qu'il y a un
barrage qui se fasse de l'autre côté de
la droite ou en marche ça me semble je
serai Sophie non aucune chance bon alors
vous me dites il va y avoir un accord
mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'a aucune
chance attention c'est enregistré c'est
noté parfaitement avoir tort et dans ce
cas là je suis prête au gage que vous
voudrez voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire sur
c'est négociations à gauche sur les
possibilités les probabilités vous avez
bien compris qu'on s'agite en coulisses
merci Sophie ravielle merci Pierre Le
Pelletier d'être avec moi d'avoir été
avec moi en charge de la gauche au
Figaro évidemment au service politique
tient une dernière question quand même
comment ça se passe comment vous raconte
les choses est-ce que vous avez pas peur
d'être un peu instrumentalisé des fois
j'imagine qu'on vous dit des
informations pour que pour les faire
passer comment on se méfie de tout ça on
essaie de les vérifier
effectivement on est conscient de ce
risque et donc on fait beaucoup plus
attention on fait toujours attention
mais surtout dans ce genre de dans ce
contexte là effectivement ce qui est
génial c'est qu'en fait Pierre et moi on
fait partie de deux générations
différentes on a des contacts différents
est-ce que à nos intérêts locuteurs
n'imagine pas forcément c'est qu'il y a
pas une feuille à papier à cigarette
entre nous donc on se dit tout on
vérifie tout et être à deux dans ce
genre de travail c'est extrêmement
précieux merci en tout cas de m'avoir
accompagné merci à Raphaël la drague en
régie la politique continue sur
figarolive je vous donne le programme
conférence de presse tout à l'heure
Jordan Bardella du rassemblement
national pour lancer les législatives
c'est à 17h point de vue présenté par
Vincent roux 18 heures il parle des
alliances mais à droite et puis et puis
oui c'est compliqué aussi et puis point
complet demain sur la situation en
Ukraine avec Vincent roseron qui vous
montrera les cartes c'est assez
passionnant voilà vous savez tout merci
de nous avoir suivi à bientôt sur figure
alive